hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video mit sandra grüße gehen raus von
sandy und ihnen gehen die grüße raus an
deine watchers schöne grüße randy und
ich mache heute eine würdest du eher
challenge auf einer website und zwar
beantworten wir einfach diese fragen wie
wir sie beantworten würden
würdest du er heute so viel kaufen
können was du willst oder jeden tag eine
sache kaufen können jeden tag eine sache
oder heute so viel kaufen könntest da
warst du willst da würde ich mir 30.000
willen kaufen und pro tag eine verkaufen
da habe ich genug moneten und mir sachen
zu kaufen für jeden tag
ich glaube dass die frage nicht
verstanden es ist doch nicht mehr würde
er das würdest du ja also ich würde
sagen jeden tag eine waffe kaufen ich
glaube auch dass es mehr leute
angekreuzt haben richtig zwei sehr gut
dann gleich 18 doofen 18 proben ja man
ja hatte war noch nie so dein ding was
hast du matte da würdest du deinen c
anstoßen oder dich an einem blatt papier
schneiden safe dich an einem blatt
papier schneiden wird die cd es gibt
nichts schlimmeres als ein schnäppchen
rändern voll gegen den tisch das auch
nicht schlimm
schon wieder nicht mehr würdest du dich
er nackt auf einen kaktus setzen oder im
skianzug in der wüste sitzen
ich würde mein lebenselexier zu 100
prozent durch einen kaktus willst du
lieber schwimmen viele persönliche und
standen dem definitiv und viele
prüfungen diesen auch wieder mbh ist
welche ende immer die schlechtere wahl
würdest du lieber nie mehr auf die
toilette gehen müssen oder nie carius
bekommen
was würdest du nehmen ich glaube nie auf
die toilette gehen müssen
ich glaube ich auch
aber wenn man so an karneval unterwegs
und die toiletten sind so voll überfüllt
dann safety auf toilette gehen müssen
sind wir um karies bekommt man einfach
nicht wenn man hält sich ordentlich die
zahlen durch die zähne putzen mit was
verschwindet man mehr zeit mit
zähneputzen also ich gucke mir dreimal
am tag die szene immer drei minuten aus
den neun minuten am tag aber toilette
war schwer also ist doch viel länger
oder aber überlegt man schon am po
zürich mit handy zu gehen ja ich auch
mal eine dreiviertelstunde wenn ich am
handy bin alter am anleger würdest du
lieber ein paar sachen über alles wissen
oder alles über wenige sachen rissen ein
paar sachen über alles wissen glaube ich
der katze immer flexen sagt jemand hasta
la vista sachse boas seine vista kommt
aus spanisch und bedeutet ich sollte
entfernt
hasta la vista
wir sehen uns
ich würde mich glaube ich trotzdem für
alles über wenige sachen wissen
entscheiden weil stämme fordern wird
sowieso themen aussuchen beispielsweise
ich würde gerne alles über chinesisch
wissen dann kannst du chinesisch
komplett fließend sprechen dann sage ich
auch noch ich würde gerne alles über
amerika wissen wird gern alles über das
weltall natürlich alles über wenige
sachen er sagte dass ich zum sachen sind
wir auf 20
ja aber alles diskutiert ich will mit
dir ja okay wir nehmen ich bin älter als
du nicht so richtig damit haben kinder
jedes jede argumentation gewonnen so
oder spiegel im spiegel hat laut spiegel
als aussteigt würdest du lieber blaue
haut haben oder rote haut haben
ich würde lieber blau aus dem rot rot
aber sagen welche rot grün schwäche dann
sehen die da laut als grün
dann überlegst nummer fünf meine nein
rot ist einfach viel natürlicher es gibt
auch leute die einfach in kranken
sonnenbrand haben dann haben sie auch
rote haut aber blau
ich würde sagen in dem rot und wir sind
safe in der mehrheit
alle wollen der arbeiter seien blaue
haut seid ihr am schalter würdest du
eher die zukunft vorhersehen können oder
in die vergangenheit sehen können
in die vergangenheit sehen können ich
will niemals in meine zukunft sehen ich
würde niemals wissen wollen wann mein
tag gekommen ist muss man sagen muss
goodbye deutschland warum will man in
die vergangenheit sehen können wir haben
einfach dich an deine kindheit zurück zu
erinnern
man kann sich doch erinnern nicht weiß
ob zum beispiel ab 14 jahren nichts mehr
4 ch ab 4
ich weiß nicht mehr ich kenne mich
irgendwie nicht meine grundschule
erinnern mag in dem safe zukunft das
haben safe mehr leute gesagt safe 68 ich
mein man kennt doch schon die
vergangenheit warum will man in die
vergangenheit sehen können das kann man
doch würdest du er wiedergeboren werden
oder in den himmel kommen ja das
impliziert hat dass man gläubig ist
unter den himmel glaubt bisschen mehr
sagen dein leben nach dem tod
ich würde obwohl neben mit wiedergeboren
das heißt ja hab ich komme in den himmel
bisschen mit anderen leuten tim in lima
also du willst lieber nach dem toten
nicht nochmal auf die erde kommen
sondern im himmel schilder erste
wiedergeboren wird ich glaube ich würde
auch lieber den himmel kommen ich glaube
noch mal aber zu sehr hängen oder am
ende bin ich beim online nutzen wollen
wir natürlich geil würdest du er bis zu
fünf meter über dem boden fliegen können
oder einen magischen teppich haben der
bis zu 50 meter über dem boden fliegen
kann also entweder du fliegst selbst
ohne irgendeinen mittel mit aber dann
nur fünf meter höhe oder 50 meter höhe
aber dafür berufsalltag teppich also ich
bin said für den teppich ich will auch
zeit für den teppich 50 meter aber es
hat gefährlich die kirche
[Musik]
bis 6
wo ich geliebt 700 meter oder suchen
also wir entscheiden uns für den teppich
auch wenn es sehr gefährlich sein jetzt
wahrscheinlich aber wir sind auch in der
mehrheit nächste frage würdest du eher
schlechtes da in ein gewinnerteam sein
oder besser an einem verlierer team sein
ich glaube ich ich bin sowieso ich
gewinne immer weil man irgendwie immer
die schlechteste deswegen stimmt das
wirklich so bei dir
ja wenn man der beste im verlierer team
ist dann wechselt man halt danach
einfach zum krasseren team
ich glaube die haben einfach ein
bisschen weiter gereist wie würdest du
eher instagram löschen oder snatch 100
würdest du lieber mit einer fettleibigen
und hässlichen person verheiratet sein
die unvorstellbar reich ist oder mit
einer wunderschönen person verheiratet
sein die sozialhilfe bekommt das erste
im ernst ich würde lieber eine
wunderschöne person nehmen
aber ich glaube über diesen sommer die
netze gehirn genutzten irgendwie hinter
hat ja diese theorie dass man die hinten
und bei manchen die wir zum verdreht bei
dir ist nicht nur eine sehr kraftvolle
wer jetzt würdest du eher betrügen oder
betrogen werden
häufig wird glaube ich eher betrügen
würdest du er das bein von einem fremden
lecken oder den finger von einem fremden
lecken ich glaube das bein ich würde
sagen auch das ja was er halt alles
angefasst hat also nehmen wir das bein
ich könnte mir nicht vorstellen von
einer fremden person einfach so den
finger nein aufgeheizten würdest du er
reich sein aber nie wieder internet
haben oder arm sein und auf der straße
leben aber immer internet 1 ich würde
zwei nehmen was nie wieder internet
nicht juckt mich nicht ich würde sagen
ich würde sagen sind mit ich also wieso
soll ich mal sein
sowieso nie so oft im internet ich bin
nur instagram und so ich wieder nie im
internet
obwohl wenn man reich jetzt kann man
auch sagen komm ich rufe jetzt nicht
meine kollegin oder meinen kollegen an
auf der welt sondern immer privat
na ja den ganzen tag
aber meine hatten eine andere frage wie
oft bisschen safari das so internet
benutzt safaris also ich bin ja nicht
nur auf safari sondern ich bin ja
instagram whatsapp alles alles mit
alles ist internet ganze smartphone das
internet fast ja
oh liebe gott mir dann bin ich lieber
haben und internet safe da gibt es nicht
so date mit jungs und so per internet
man muss ja würdest du lieber eine nacht
in einem geisterhaus verbringen oder
eine minute in einem raum voller spinnen
ich bin ein gitter des buchs du auch
aber ich glaube dass rehwild schlimm
aber ich glaube einem raum voller spinn
ich glaube ich auch wenn der eine stunde
stehen würde dann würde ich mir noch
überlegen sei aber auch dass jetzt 50 50
dass auch kraß anders elements er nicht
dass heute wieder so beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn euch diese würdest
du lieber challenge gefallen hat dann
dass sein junge
[Musik]